health care workers and first responders
may be first in line for the coronavirus
vaccine
but an alarming number are refusing it
the la times reporting
40 percent of local firefighters failed
to even show up at a vaccine drive last
week
fox news medical contributor dr nicole
sapphire is here to react
doctor thanks for being here so
obviously when you see stuff like this i
think it makes people nervous because
they say to themselves well
if medical professionals and first-line
responders aren't getting it do they
know something we don't and should i
wait
what are your thoughts of course
jedidiah and i can understand why um
hearing some of these headlines may
cause people some concern
and it's not just the la firefighters
really it's being seen all across the
country where there are people opting
not to have
get received the vaccine and it's
happening for a variety of reasons
some people feel that they don't need it
they don't believe that they're high
enough risk to either contracting it or
they don't believe that they would have
severe illness if they got it
others have some vaccine hesitancy we
know that that runs rampant throughout
the united states due to
some conspiracy theories that people are
claiming that
the research was rushed there was a lot
of politization of the scientific
process when it came to making these
vaccines
and so unfortunately it has really
muddied the waters and it has
it has had a very unfortunate result
when it comes to vaccines
now i want to tell you jedidiah if you
look at flu vaccines every year about
only 35 to 40 percent of american
adults actually get the flu vaccine and
that's because
a lot of um health care workers are
actually forced to get if they work in
health care setting
so we know that a far majority of adults
don't actually get normal vaccines
anyway so covered 19 i'm not surprised
that people aren't getting it
however jedidiah here's my biggest
concern i think people have really
normalized
um this virus and this infection because
it's been going on for so long and
people have coveted fatigue which we've
talked about
but you know jedi people who get it say
you know they make the
the comment of you know i still haven't
gotten my sense of smell or taste back
and it's been several months
but let me tell you why that is so
serious jedediah
losing your sense of taste and smell
that's not just your congested and you
can't smell your coffee that morning
that means that your central nervous
system has been affected by this virus
and long covered syndrome those symptoms
that are lasting three months six months
and even longer after
after that initial infection those are
becoming much more prominent
in about 20 percent of people that test
positive i mean that's a big that's a
big deal jenna
this virus is serious we still have
record-breaking people being
hospitalized and dying every day
we have to take it seriously yeah i'm
not so interested in who's getting the
vaccine but how many people are getting
the vaccine and that's what we need to
focus on
getting on getting this vaccine into as
many arms of americans as possible to
reach that level of immunity so we can
move on with our lives
yeah yeah we know that a lot of the
lingering systems symptoms for people
involve lungs but also as you mentioned
neurological i've heard a lot of that
from a lot of people
uh that got covered six seven eight
months ago i wanna just quickly we don't
have a lot of time to quickly touch on
something in new jersey which is that
smokers can now get vaccinated before
teachers and before public transit
workers that's causing a lot of
controversy
we only have about 20 seconds but can
you tell us your thoughts on that
again jedidiah at this point we need to
just open it up to everybody and anybody
who wants the vaccines
smoking unfortunately we have 34 million
americans still smoking cigarettes
it causes chronic illness and cancers
and if we want to keep our hospitals
functioning
we actually do need to get the vaccine
to those that are vulnerable and people
that smoke are
but again i don't think it should be
restricted to them i think anybody that
wants the vaccine we need to try and get
it to them as soon as possible
yeah dr nicole sapphire thanks for being
here as always
thank you